PATHIK SHARMA: Hello, everyone.
And thanks for joining.
Over the period of
last year, we have
been on a mission to
help our customers get
the most out of their
Google Cloud investments.
This has taken the form of
consolidating some of the best
practices on GCP, as well as
helping customers identify
potential area of improvements
within that people, process,
and culture while
operating in Cloud.
My name is Pathik Sharma,
and I work in Google Cloud
Professional Services.
With me joining here
is Scott from Open X.
Today, we will be
reviewing a few key areas
that we have had the pleasure
of investigating while working
directly with our
most complex customers
as they usher in the next
generation of applications,
features, and
customer experiences.
We will be discussing the Cloud
landscape, especially the mind
shift that needs to occur when
going from predictable Capex
model to variable
Cloud based OpEx model.
[INAUDIBLE] there are
some console changes
that needs to occur
before you realize
the true value of Cloud.
Next up, we will be
discussing cost optimization
recommendations that
have come up frequently
by reviewing the customer
cost over the last year.
Later in the presentation,
we will have the opportunity
to hear from one of our
favorite [INAUDIBLE] customer
OpenX, who is very well
versed in cost optimization
as a practice.
Scott will tell us a bit
about their experience
on how they optimized
their cost on Google Cloud.
So let's get started.
Putting together the
best and brightest
that Google has offered to
research in this mission,
we have spent considerable
amount of time, effort, sweat,
and sometimes tears to
present this very astonishing
conclusion when it
comes to Cloud cost.
And that is, no customer wants
to spend more than they need to
on their Cloud investment.
From the field, we
have seen customers
migrate their
in-house applications
onto Cloud infrastructure
to unlock cost savings.
However, as reality surfaces,
the savings that were promised
doesn't really materialize.
And we wanted to
know why that is.
As we dove deeper, we found
that the very feature that
makes Cloud a shining
opportunity to reduce IT cost
could end up being more
expensive if not leveraged
appropriately.
For example, due to on-demand
and elastic nature of Cloud,
procurement is now
pushed to the edge.
Engineers can now spend company
money by spending resources
without traditional
finance approval.
Due to this,
sometimes it's easier
to see an increase in cost,
but difficult to pinpoint where
exactly it is coming from.
The variable OpEx model of
Cloud with literally thousands
of cost line items and hundred
more popping every quarter
doesn't help either.
A common notion we see is that
Cloud cost is not predictable.
So we need a
framework that is well
understood by finance who
is trying to understand
the variable OpEx
model, by engineers
that has to consider
cost as a metric,
just like reliability and
security of the application,
and by management that looks at
the value created by the Cloud,
then just the number
of dollars spent.
As we discussed
more and more, we
realized some of
the things we take
for granted in our experience
might not be immediately
evident to someone who has
decided to begin their Cloud
journey.
That brings us to
why do we care?
Being in professional
services, we align ourselves
with our customers' initiatives
to build deeper trust
and long term relationship.
Turns out, as part of the
research, 73% of organization
plan to optimize their Cloud
spend, making it top initiative
for the fourth year in a row.
Only to [INAUDIBLE] this year
due do the global pandemic.
So we want to help you, even
if it means you spending less
with us.
All right.
So let's begin the journey
starting with the goal in mind.
We have seen customers
take advantage of Cloud
to launch faster go
to marketing strategy,
enable themselves to
be [INAUDIBLE] quickly.
And last but not
least, make customer
happier by serving them
during their constantly
changing needs.
And we see that customer
realize that it's not
just about spending less.
But it's actually
making more by realizing
the true value of Cloud.
So then the question
is, how do you
achieve all your goals while
being efficient in what you do?
Well for one, understanding that
cost is more than just a cost
center.
Our most sophisticated customers
aren't fixated on specific cost
cutting numbers, but they are
asking variety of questions
to improve their
overall fitness.
What are we providing
to our customers?
Is it a product?
A service?
Or I will take an
example for instance.
Machine learning powered
memes that are really funny.
And we call it Meme
Generator 2000.
How much does it cost me
to provide that and only
that thing?
You're looking at
cost per service
as it makes sense
for the business.
Going back to my example,
I'm looking at all the Cloud
infrastructure cost
that goes into creating
memes, and delivering it to
various social media platforms.
Lastly, how can I optimize
all the correlated
spend by unit creative?
And that brings us to
optimizing at all layers that
makes up this service.
Ultimately, we see conversation
gearing towards unit economies.
In my example, $100
of my Cloud spend
is generating 1,000 memes,
and 10,000 impressions,
overall generating
a revenue of $200,
and a happiness
score of 10 on 10.
So now, rather than
looking at my Cloud cost,
I'm looking at
average cost per meme,
along with the happiness score.
Because that's the true
value for my business.
So my goal is to reduce
the per unit cost.
So where do we start?
Well first up, it's
[INAUDIBLE] to know
where your cost is coming from.
Once you know what
makes up your cost,
the next step is to optimize.
So let's look at the
equation for Cloud cost.
It is resources used
multiplied by the rate paid
for the resource.
So optimization ultimately comes
down to efficiency in your use
it and pricing.
Let's look at all the
tools available to you
to enhance the visibility
and governance at all layers.
We will break this
down into three areas
for predictable Cloud spend.
Visibility, accountability,
and control.
Within visibility, you
have built-in report,
cost breakdown, and
cost table to provide
all the information you need
in terms of use it and cost.
For more customized
views, we often
see customers use
raw billing data
by enabling BigQuery Export to
slice and dice the information
as it makes sense
for the business.
We recommend turning
on BigQuery Billing
Export for historical
analysis and trends.
For accountability, resource
hierarchy and labeling
are extremely powerful ways
to allocate cost or business
unit, service, cost
control group, or really
anything you want it to be.
This should be standardized
and enforced systematically.
With this tool, you
should be able to identify
any and all costs that
makes up your service.
It doesn't matter if you are
a startup spending thousands
or multinational corporations
spending millions per month.
Again, you don't want everyone
to see your organization cost.
So Google Cloud provides
granular permissioning
that fits your need.
Moving on to
controlling your cost.
Our advanced customers
identifies the slightest leak
in their Cloud cost by using
budget and alerting feature.
Not only that.
If they suddenly see
a spike of cost coming
from a non-production
environment,
customer take automated
action to identify and rectify
the cost.
You also have the ability to
be proactive and get alerted
on the forecasted increase of
cost, versus once the damage is
done.
And lastly, you
have quotas that can
help throttle or cap your cost
to prevent budget overruns.
One thing I will leave
you with on this light is,
don't wait for the traditional
monthly or quarterly review
of cost.
We have seen successful
customers review their cost
as frequently as daily.
All right.
So let's take a look
at recommendations
that have come up frequently.
But before we jump there,
our advanced customers
knows when to stop the
train to make changes
that can help them run leaner.
It is important to understand
what is the potential savings
and level of effort required
to optimize anything.
This will help you prioritize
your recommendations.
So rather than saying,
hey, we can save some money
by moving all these
memes to quota storage
as they are not
accessed frequently.
The conversation now shifts to
not moving to quota [INAUDIBLE]
can cost us $100,000 this month.
But will take two weeks
of engineering effort
to implement this.
The better optics you
have, the more accurately
you can pinpoint potential
savings and relative effort.
Now, prioritizing
recommendation is important
because there are hundreds
of ways you can run leaner,
some of which are shown here.
Some easier to implement,
like Committed Use Discounts,
which gives you up to 57%
discount for your always
on workflow.
Or getting rid of
ideal Cloud resources
that doesn't provide
any business value.
That's 100% discount
right there.
Some recommendations are going
to be architecture aware,
like autoscaling, to scale the
resources up and down based
on user activity.
Or the use of preemptable VMs
for stateless workload, which
gives you up to 80% discount.
Lastly, there are
some recommendations
that are going to be
game changer, especially
for our heavy users.
Like Storage Lifecycle
Management and BigQuery flat
rate [INAUDIBLE].
I would love to go
through each one of these
into great details on when
to use one versus the other.
But unfortunately, we
are tight on time there.
The presentation will
be made available to you
so you have the
ability to dive deeper.
While not on, I
will certainly go
through some
recommendations that
are provided by Active Assist.
If you haven't heard
of Active Assist,
it is unlocking Google magic
across your Cloud deployment.
We are going to use
our specialities
around data analysis
and machine learning
to provide you recommendations
based on your usage.
Let's review resource
optimization first.
We understand for small and
large organizations alike,
it's easy to spend up
resources and forget about it.
So in this case, Active
Assist will [INAUDIBLE]
ideal instances
and disks to you.
If it doesn't provide
any business value,
you can quickly
optimize your Cloud cost
by turning it off or
just deleting that.
Not only [INAUDIBLE] instances,
but over provisioning VMs
is a very common runaway cost.
Active Assist will surface
these opportunities
and suggest right sizing to
further reduce your cost.
When we looked at a couple
of examples of resource
optimization, let's
optimize the rate
you pay for Cloud resources.
You can now easily
you're always on workload
that can be benefited by
committed use discounts.
Learning to guess
what your saving
is going to be because
Active Assist will
do all the heavy lifting
for you and provide
you an easy to understand
actionable recommendations.
Last but not the least, for
heavy users of BigQuery,
Active Assist will
recommend best billing model
based on your usage.
In addition to
cost optimization,
it can also help
your infrastructure
to be more reliable,
secure, and performant.
But there are dozens
[INAUDIBLE] available today.
We are working on one.
Not every recommendation is
going to be impactful for you.
Some will be good means,
others will be transformative.
We have seen successful examples
of many customer optimizing
their total cost of
ownership by leveraging
Google managed services, as
well as serverless offering
to offload all the
operational overhead
and allow you to focus on things
that matters to your business.
This pandemic will force
business to re-imagine ways
to operate with
efficiency at all layers.
I believe the issue is not
so much in understanding
Cloud technology.
But it is the standardization
of process and shift in culture
that is required in realizing
the true value of Cloud.
Now because there are
so many moving parts,
it's not one
person's job anymore.
You need a team.
Some decisions are
best centralized,
like purchasing
committed use discounts,
or standardizing cost
allocation strategy.
Whereas others are more
effective when decentralized,
like re-factoring your
application and right sizing.
Because the
application owner knows
what's best given their
current architecture.
No matter what you
decide to improve,
always define metric,
set target goals,
and measure often to
track your progress.
For example, for my application,
Meme Generator 2000,
I want committed use discount
coverage and utilization
to be above 90%.
That's my target.
Avoid going from 0 to hero.
Start slow.
Get real-time feedback
and [INAUDIBLE] overtime.
In industry standard
terms, that's
learning to crawl and walk
first before you drive.
I mentioned real-time
feedback, which
is very critical
element for creating
a cost conscious culture,
as it can help you course
correct sooner.
Think of Prius effect.
It drives better behaviors.
We have also seen
customers gamify
the impact, which gets everyone
excited in greeting a shared
goal.
A quick look.
Check out our white
paper and other assets
for comprehensive view
on cost optimization.
Here are some quick wins we have
seen across multiple customers
when helping them over
the period of last year.
Now, I would like
to hand it over
to Scott from OpenX for
their transformative journey.
SCOTT SNELL: Thank you Pathik.
Hi, my name is Scott Snell.
And I've been working with OpenX
on our Google Cloud migration.
OpenX is a leader and
programmatic advertising,
and we operate one of the
world's largest ad exchanges.
We reach nearly a
billion consumers,
and we work with more
than 30,000 advertisers
across every screen and device.
My focus has been on Cloud
cost management and cost
optimization.
Thank you all for joining.
I'm excited to share some of
the cost optimization learnings
from OpenX.
Here is our agenda.
I'll briefly cover the
challenges for OpenX
in moving to GCP.
I'll share how we
prioritized things
early on from a governance and
cost management perspective.
Next, I'll cover our approach
to cost visibility and share
a number of examples of how
we were able to implement
various cost optimizations.
We'll finish up with a
review of lessons learned.
So the challenge
was how to migrate
15 million lines of
code from six data
centers worldwide in six months.
OpenX consumes a significant
amount of compute, network,
and storage resources.
And we process trillions
of events per day.
In terms of migrating to
GCP, the engineering teams
did all of the heavy lifting
and did a fantastic job.
And the migration was a success.
But early on in the
migration effort,
we needed to organize how we
were going to get started.
So let's talk about that.
At the beginning of the
project, Paul Ryan, our CTO,
laid out a high level
Cloud migration roadmap.
We started with a
focus on governance,
whereby we set out
to establish controls
around product ownership,
cost responsibility, roles
and budgets, and
resource management,
including folder
organization, project naming
conventions, and required
project labels and SKU labels.
From that foundation,
we could focus
on cost visibility
and ultimately,
on cost optimization.
Let's first talk
about cost visibility.
Our cost visibility
efforts have helped
us understand what we
were spending money on,
sliced on a variety
of dimensions.
For example, by projects,
by service, by region,
and by label, to name
just a few dimensions.
In addition to aggregate
cost visibility,
we were focusing on
per unit cost metrics.
Also, we prioritized cost
visibility around usage type,
namely preemptible, on-demand,
and committed to use.
And we turned on
GKE usage metering
to measure our Kubernetes costs
by app, by cluster, and region.
So how did we set up our
cost reporting framework?
For some GCP customers,
the GCP console
may provide a good
start to cost reporting.
Early on, we turned on
Billing Data Export, which
is highly recommended,
and started
to integrate various data
sources into our recording
framework.
We used Data Studio and
BigQuery for the majority
of our cost reporting.
One of our key metrics
is how many ad requests
do we receive each day?
And what does it cost
us to process each one?
We did this by integrating our
GCP billing data with our OpenX
performance data.
This enabled us to get insights
into per unit costs as well
as gross margin performance.
In terms of frequency
of reporting,
we look at cost reporting
daily, and we send out
a cost summary email each
day to various teams.
Now that I've touched on how we
set things up from a governance
cost visibility and
reporting standpoint,
we will turn our attention
to cost optimization.
This grid represents
various cost optimizations
in terms of
complexity of the work
relative to the expected
cost saving benefits.
Also, we have organized
the optimizations
into four buckets:
usage optimization,
pricing efficiency, waste
reduction, and refactoring.
We are working on or
have completed work
on all of the above.
Overall, we have completed more
than 30 significant Cloud cost
optimizations.
I'll share some examples
in the following slides.
First I'll share two examples
of usage optimizations.
The first usage
optimization example
is around saving
money on egress.
We saw that we were
spending a lot of money
on egress between zones, which
is called interzone egress
in our regional clusters.
See the orange
bars on this chart.
By shifting to multi
zonal clusters,
we were able to reduce
interzone egress costs to 0
without impacting
other egress costs.
The second usage
optimization example
is around changing
the machine shape
to better match
utilization of CPU and RAM.
By evaluating
resource utilization
within a specific
project, we found
that we were fully
utilizing memory,
but under utilizing CPU.
See the purple bars.
By changing the
machine shape, we
were able to reduce costs
by 25% within this project.
The last two examples were
about usage optimization.
In the next few examples,
we'll cover pricing efficiency,
finding the best price
solution for your work.
The first pricing
efficiency example,
and the most
important, is around
leveraging discounted compute
rates for preemptible machines
and implementing
committed use discounts.
The red line represents
on-demand compute VCPUs.
You can see a nice drop off in
our on-demand usage over time.
Running more services
on preemptible machines,
the gold line, had a very
dramatic cost reduction.
Also note that some
refactoring may
be required to run preemptible.
The blue line
represents our increased
three-year commitment.
This change also led to a
significant cost reduction.
The combination of preemptible
machines and committed use
discounts dramatically
reduced our costs.
The second pricing
efficiency example
is around flat rate
pricing for BigQuery.
We are a heavy user of
BigQuery, both for storage
and for querying.
We found that our on-demand
analysis costs were very spiky,
and we had days where we
spent way more than expected.
By committing to
flat rate pricing,
we were able to better
control our costs.
The downside is that some
queries may take longer
to run if capacity demands
exceeded committed capacity.
In our case, our
queries were primarily
for analysis purposes.
So we refined making a
performance trade off.
As a result, our
on-demand cost dropped,
and we attained a more
stable cost for BigQuery.
The third and final
pricing efficiency example
is around reducing
storage costs.
By choosing the most cost
effective storage class,
we reduced storage
costs by 50% by shifting
from regional storage,
the blue bars,
to a blend of coldline
and nearline storage.
Also, while we are on
the subject of storage,
we've done a lot of work with
data retention policy changes,
a form of waste reduction.
And these have also had
a cost saving impact.
So what kind of cost impact did
these and other optimizations
have?
I mentioned earlier that one
of our key areas of focus
was on optimizing
our per unit costs.
One important cost
metric that we track
is cost per ad request.
This chart shows our cost
per ad request over time.
Through a combination of
usage optimization, pricing
efficiency, waste reduction, and
a fair amount of refactoring,
we have reduced our per
unit costs by more than 60%
since September of last year.
This is all during a time
of increased ad unit growth.
Now we'll wrap up with
some lessons learned.
Here are some key takeaways
from our experience
optimizing costs in GCP.
Cost management and optimization
is not a one person job.
Your success will
depend on good teamwork
across the organization.
It might be boring
work, but an early focus
on governance, resource
management, and controls
will help pave the way
to success in the Cloud.
Early on, we had
a few days of pain
with costs that
spiraled out of control.
At the top of our
do-overs list, would
be to implement
project budgeting
and or cost spike detection
even earlier than we did.
Where possible, utilize
preemptible machines.
And for long term
consistent usage
that would otherwise
be on-demand,
it may be worth it to make a one
year or three year commitment.
Finally, there are
many different ways
to optimize costs in the Cloud.
Cost optimizations vary with
level of effort and the cost
saving impact.
So prioritize accordingly.
Now I'll hand it back to Pathik.
Thank you.
PATHIK SHARMA: Thanks
Scott for taking us
through that transformative
journey of OpenX.
It doesn't matter
if you are a startup
or 100-year-old enterprise.
Process and optimization
tips shared in this session,
and by Scott, can be leveraged
across all types of customers.
If you still need help, engage
Google Cloud Professional
Services to jump start your
cost performance journey.